on a besoin de réformer l'assurance
chômage parce que dans une politique de
l'emploi dans une politique qui veut
faire en sorte que le marché du travail
soit le plus inclusif possible
on doit utiliser tous les leviers qui
sont à notre disposition
alors il existe bien évidemment des
leviers qui consiste à activer un
certain nombre de mécanismes des dalles
embauche d'accompagnement je dirais des
demandeurs d'emploi pour leur permettre
d'accéder à l'emploi mais il existe
aussi les leviers au système
d'indemnisation aux critères
d'indemnisation du chômage
c'est le biais là ils sont multiples ils
sont parfois extrêmement compliqué mais
ce sont des leviers qui peuvent être
extrêmement puissant pour inciter les
différents acteurs qui sont des acteurs
qui font des choix économique rationnel
dans leur manière de préparer d'activer
leur recherche d'emploi dans le type
d'emploi qu'ils peuvent être amenés à
rechercher et bien ces leviers de les
adapter le mieux possible pour permettre
de répondre aux besoins du marché du
travail
l'un des objectifs de la réforme c'est
précisément de faire en sorte qu'on
accède plus favorablement à d emploi de
longue durée à des emplois en cdi ou à
des cdd de plus longue durée est l'un
des leviers qui est utilisé à cette fin
c'est le mode de calcul
l'exemple que je peux vous prendre c'est
celui de deux travailleurs de deux
personnes l'une qui travaille à mi-temps
en cdi et l'autre qui travaille un jour
sur deux à temps plein sur des emplois
en cdd pour une même quantité de travail
sur la même période
et bien malheureusement le système tel
qu'il était organisée aboutissait à
pénaliser la personne qui était en cdi
au profit de la personne qui était
employé en période de cdd entrecoupées
de périodes de reprise de travail ça ne
sera plus le cas avec les nouvelles
règles de calcul
[Musique]